when Schultz's star passed through the
ort Cloud it came five times closer than
Proxima centor the closest star to our
solar system but when it does it could
shake the Earth quite a
bit at first the rogar would make its
way into the ort Cloud at this point it
wouldn't affect us directly but it would
send massive chunks of Space Rock
showering the solar system comets and
meteors might not seem like a big deal
since most of them are small they often
fall in unpopulated regions but back in
1908 in Siberia it only took one
asteroid to obliterate 880,000 trees and
blow out windows 60 km away if the same
asteroid were to hit New York the entire
city would be in the Impact
Zone all that if just a single star
smaller than the Sun Slightly made it
just inside our solar system